[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to our installments of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the ministry of magic the
wizarding world as a whole
and guns in a world full of powerful
spells that bear extreme destructive
potential
i've always wondered what the mindset is
surrounding guns in a wizarding world
we don't see guns much and i think that
the most notable instance of a wizard
showing their attitude towards guns
is when hagrid bends vernon does a
shotgun and a philosopher's stone
hagrid's not even remotely afraid of the
gun being pointed at him
but i don't think it's because he feels
that he's invulnerable to it it's
because he knows that vernon is too much
of a coward
to actually properly pull the trigger
and impale him but
that does sort of make me wonder how
destructive could a weapon like a gun
actually be in the wizarding world
surely it wouldn't overshadow magic
otherwise witches and wizards would be
using guns just like muggles
right i did some digging online and
there seems to be a general consensus
among many fans
that at one point in time rowling
actually spoke on this matter
revealing that the power of a gun in
many instances outweighs the power of
magic
specifically in the instance of a jewel
in a fight between a muggle with a
shotgun and a wizard with a wand
the muggle will win however i'm really
not sure of the legitimacy of this quote
i'd really have to find the exact source
to go by this i'm also not convinced
i think that though a gun could bear
some destructive potential magic is so
much more versatile
in the wizarding world there also never
seems too much of an emphasis placed on
the use of guns
it just isn't part of their culture the
ministry of magic is a primary form of
government in the magical world
at least in the uk and they are
responsible for establishing and
upholding all legislation
pertaining to the laws of the magical
world other countries have a similar
structure of government
but have different names i.e in the u.s
there is macusa
the magical congress of the united
states of america like a mughal
government the ministry's
responsibilities are vast
as they are the primary body that
attempts to sustain law and order in the
magical world
and like any system of government in an
effort to cover as much ground as
possible
the primary governmental body is
systematically divided to focus on
different sectors of the wizarding world
there are 10 levels of the ministry of
magic in total
and the government has been around for a
long time as the ministry of magic was
preceded by the wizards council the
longest serving form of government that
served britain
the wizards council eventually turned
into the ministry of magic in the year
as it needed an overhaul it lacked
structure and needed to be brought into
more modern times
however what i've always found
interesting about both forms of
wizarding government that have existed
is there is no legislation at all
pertaining to the use of guns
the closest thing that the ministry of
magic has is the misuse of muggle
artifacts office
but this is nothing guns are a massively
controversial item
in muggle government and there is
boatloads of legislation surrounding the
possession
handling use and trade of guns given
that the first recorded use of a firearm
was in 1364
one would expect there would be
something more in place to control the
use of such deadly weapons
not just nothing at all which is what it
looks like we know that witches and
wizards are not impervious to
traditional physical harm
they get hit by things think bludgers
and often they aren't physically
different than a muggle
they have the same skin the same nerve
endings and they are just as vulnerable
as a regular person
bearing this in mind then i think it's a
safe bet to say that witches and wizards
also wouldn't be invulnerable to bullets
given that witches from wizards possess
the ability to turn objects into
projectiles
think voldemort and the glass in a
ministry atrium who is stopping them
from just grabbing
say a gun and using that wouldn't that
be more convenient
first of all i think the primary reason
that guns aren't used by the large
majority of witches and wizards
is the fact that it's just as i
mentioned earlier not a part of their
culture
they don't exist anywhere they're not
advertised no one owns them
there's no legislation surrounding them
and certainly no one is using them
they grow up in a world entirely devoid
of weapons like that
and i suppose that aspect of muggle
culture just never found its way in
however we know of course that in
addition to the witches and wizards that
have spent their entire lives in the
wizarding world
there are also witches and wizards that
grew up in the muggle world
and spent a considerable amount of time
there before attending hogwarts
presumably these witches and wizards are
at least familiar with muggle technology
like guns so if anyone were to consider
using a weapon like a gun
then these would be the people so why
don't these half blood and
muggle-born witches and wizards spice up
the battle against the death eaters
and pull out some guns i think that one
of the main reasons that guns are never
used
is because witches and wizards don't
want to adopt that part of mughal's
society
or many other parts of mughal's society
for that matter the primary goal of the
ministry of magic
and wizarding government is upholding
the statute of secrecy
which upholds the divide between muggle
and magical worlds
this is best explained by hagrid to
harry in the philosopher's stone
ministry of magic messing things up as
usual there's a ministry of magic
of course they wanted dumbledore for
minister of course but he'd never leave
hogwarts
so old cornelius fudge got the job
bangla if there ever was one
so he pelts dumbledore with hours every
morning asking for advice
but what does the ministry of magic do
well their main job is to keep it from
the muggles that they're still witches
and wizards up and down the country
why why blimey harry everyone would be
wanting magical solutions to their
problems
nah we're best left alone what this
means is that
among all of the things that the
ministry handles their ultimate
responsibility is to ensure
there is a harmonious and distinctly
segregated relationship with the muggle
world
secrecy is of utmost importance however
in this passage hagrid seems to suggest
the statute of secrecy is upheld because
muggles would want things from witches
and wizards
they'd want magical solutions to their
problems and who knows what would come
with that however i am of the stance
that the statute of secrecy
is primarily upheld out of fear in
dumbledore's copy of the wizard and the
hopping pot
a short story written by beetle de bard
that focuses on wizarding michael
relations
he scribbled in his own notes that read
as the witch hunts grew ever fiercer
wizarding families began to live double
lives using charms of concealment to
protect themselves and their families
by the 17th century any witch or wizard
who chose to fraternize with muggles
became suspect even an outcast in his or
her own community
what this tells us is that preceding the
17th century
the world was very much wide open the
presence of witches and wizards was well
known to muggles
and did muggles welcome them into their
society no
they hunted them down and this is what
effectively coined the term
witch hunt they didn't praise them for
their magical ability
and welcomed them with open arms they
hunted them down because they were
different because they were freaks when
the ministry of magic formed
in 1707 proper regulation was put in
place
began to separate the two worlds and the
wizarding community
wanted to distance themselves from
muggles as much as possible
this meant adopting as little from their
culture as possible and this would
include guns
ones are distinctly a witch and wizard's
item it's not anything that a muggle
would have any use for
and i think that by sticking with ones
and avoiding guns witches and wizards
are holding onto a piece of their
identity
like the way that purebloods are
disgusted with the notion of muggle and
wizard breeding
i would imagine that it would be a huge
faux pas to take advantage of muggle
technology
i think that on some level witches and
wizards know this if muggles wanted to
take over
they could they are much weaker
individually and they rely on technology
but they massively and i mean massively
outweigh the wizarding population
they also happen to have technology that
does put them on more of a level playing
field
hogwarts which is the primary
introduction to the wizarding world for
muggleborns
seems to place a huge emphasis on the
importance of the divide between the two
worlds
and i think this is for good reason
they're taught very early on that they
are two completely different places
and need to be treated as such you can't
bring muggle values into
the wizarding world in the same way that
you can't bring wizarding values into
the muggle world
and i think they know on some level that
using a gun or any powerful muggle
technology for that matter
would cause imbalance the introduction
of a powerful weapon
like a gun to the wizarding society
would cause it to implode
i think the morally righteous witches
and wizards know not to use them for
this reason
they understand the importance of
separation and i think the morally
dubious witches and wizards
would never touch them out of contempt a
death eater would be disgusted by the
prospect of using muggle technology
and that's it for this video i hope you
enjoyed it what do you think
why don't witches and wizards use guns
in harry potter let me know down in the
comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
hurry